the multi-talented ken rosenthal back
here on the show how are you Ken how are
you I'm doing fine so let's start with
the Red Sox what makes them so good in
your estimation Ken
wow that's a great question because
there's so much about them that I like I
would say most of all it's their
positioning group and that starts with
the three outfielders and JD Martinez
but obviously they've got depth across
that roster starting pitching has been
good the bullpen fortified board by
Porcello they just have a way about them
and I don't know that they're the most
talented team I don't know if they were
talented as Houston in many regards and
Houston had on paper got a bullpen the
better rotation but all season long they
have one game they figure out ways to
win game they can do it a lot of
different ways and that to me is kind of
what defines them and the birthday boy
from last night Alex Cora
he's uh he's got the stuff man he's just
knows what buttons to push he gets he
gets the most out of everybody what do
you think he brings to the equation that
makes him so good as well Ken he has a
way about him that the players respond
to and if you go back to last year not
the best John Farrell but nan Farrell
was not as loose with the players he did
not give off a relaxed vibe at all now
it's not that Cory is relaxed he's a
very intense competitor but just kind of
a good way about him he's honest with
his players open with them he was a
player himself not long ago so all of
that when combined with his
open-mindedness towards the analytical
part of the equation that has become
such an integral part of everything now
and his ability to communicate that to
players and have his coaching staff
communicate that to players that is all
part of his leadership - it's just been
for him a remarkable run here and yet
they're a good team and sure a manager
can only do so much with a good team but
we have seen over the years many times
were imagined can screw up a good team
and he has not done that quite the
opposite he's brought more out
this club and I think most of us thought
so coming into this ALCS ken rosenthal
if I'd told you one of these two facts
which would have been the more
surprising one to you one is that Jackie
Bradley jr. would be the MVP of the ALCS
or to David Price would win Game five to
wrap things up after having a solid game
two outing
I had three that the Red Sox would win
in five games okay surprising I don't
know but all are surprising Jackie
Bradley jr. is a talented guy has not
been a consistent hitter throughout his
career at times he is really slumped and
people have said well he gives them the
defense and that's why he is out there
but as he is shown he has ability and at
times he gets to get streaky but at
times when it's hot he's a very dynamic
offensive player David Price I always go
by the theory and he tested this theory
that good players eventually find a way
to succeed in the postseason and it goes
back to bonds it goes back even before
him on if you remember struggling the
post days and then finally in 2002
figured it out he gave it a great player
enough chances they're going to figure
it out but as I said price didn't test
that theory I did not know if it was
ever going to end up like last night and
it's so interesting to me that last
night he was perhaps put in the worst
position he has been put in in any of
his postseason starts three days rest
warming up the night before and somehow
he found it and I heard saw him stay
after the game and he found something in
the bullpen the night before and
whatever it was changeup was good the
fastball location was really good and
that was the David Price that we've seen
so often in his career has been amazing
it's been amazing before before you move
on to the NLCS and then the World Series
what what is the post-mortem on the 2018
Astros do you think Ken
I don't know and certainly they were a
talented group and in my view the best
team in baseball all year even though
the Red Sox won more games I thought
they had no flaws look at the Red Sox
bullpen is a flaw they in the rotation
were vulnerable because Sale had the
physical issues price was unreliable in
bigger games and Houston just seemed to
have it all they certainly were banged
up toward the end Altuve was not out too
bad because of the knee and that
affected them Korea get a good playoff
but during the course of the regular
season he struggled with the back
they're gonna be back they do have a
number of free agents and some of them
are kind of core players Michael Charlie
Morton Marlin Gonzalez those are three
of the big ones
Brian McCann's and other they're still
going to be a powerhouse it's very
difficult to go back-to-back we know
that it only happens what hasn't
happened since the Yankees the late 90s
2000 so I don't have a clear postmortem
because I'm still a little bit stunned
they only won one game in this series
but what shocked me was the middle three
games of the five-game set they allowed
I believe was seven seven and eight
interesting team that I thought had just
brilliant pitching chose the depth of
the Red Sox lineup and how devastating
it can be well do they have do they have
a hit reputationally to Ken with what
Yahoo Sports would reported with this
fellow who who had a credential from the
the Astros shooting pictures of opposing
dugouts ken is there anything to this is
there any there there both those things
are blemishes now certainly the part
about the employee that you just
mentioned now baseball has essentially
said this matter is closed and they took
care of it
other teams are not happy with that
explanation they think the Astros go too
far went too far I don't know where that
goes
the sign stealing thing has been an
issue for a while now I remember writing
about it last offseason just have
baseball is installing new phones so
they can monitor them things couldn't
communicate from the clubhouse to the
Doug
and yet because of the vast amount of
electronics available teams find
different ways and do what they do
now that was certainly something that if
the esters had won the World Series
people would have wondered hey was this
okay and the a sort of thing is another
question there are certain teams that
would not have acquired Roberto Osuna
after he served seventy five game
suspension for domestic violence the
Astros did a lot of people thought that
was kind of a cynical act basically
saying we don't care whatever the guy
has done doesn't matter to us he's a
great performer we'll take him again
other teams did not make that decision
so they didn't win the World Series some
of this noise will die down and I'm not
calling it noise in the center of
needless noise it's very legitimate
noise but going forward will be
interesting to see kind of how these
things progress with the Astros do they
make that same kind of acquisition the
next time do they calm down or do they
not do what they've done with this some
person who was taking pictures his
dugout and doing heavens knows never
knows what else remember they said they
were playing defense right yeah right
all the other teams are worried about it
all of them are doing stuff just a
matter of how much well it's something
and I'll bring up with uh with John
McClain of Houston Chronicle he joins us
to the third hour but right now I've got
Ken Rosenthal from Fox and the athletic
here on the Rich Eisen show you are in
Milwaukee now I assume correct sir for
tonight's game okay what do you think
what what what was Craig Counsell doing
with Wade Miley I know that you've
written about it for the athletic and
I'll talk more about that in a second
but what was it what was that whole
gambit with Wade Miley about well the
way the Brewers eat is they have a hard
time matching up with the Dodgers from a
pitching standpoint the Dodgers are so
deep offensively and so versatile
left-handed hitters right-handed hitters
in step that it's difficult to get a
match of advantage of platoon advantage
so what they're thinking was dart Miley
or at least announced Miley the Dodgers
will put mostly right-handers in as they
did all the two of their hitters were
right hand
and then flip the line up or flip the
equation by putting in the right-hander
Woodruff and you have the patern
advantage against all of those
right-handed hitters you force the
Dodgers do basically empty their bench
and it's a reasonable thing to do if
you're the Brewers because one you don't
have the starting pitching depth that
other teams do you don't have enough
starters to go through seven-game series
and to because of the Dodgers unique
grouping of position players it's very
unusual to see if all-stars or former
all-stars on the bench the way they have
them so that's why they did it and by
doing it they got Miley tonight on five
days rest instead of three days rest
which would have been the first time in
his career he had done that and they are
actually set up quite well from a
pitching standpoint tonight cater is
rested Jeffers has rested Knable is
rested from the bullpens perspective so
this is it and this is their shot they
had to do these kinds of things to
compete with the Dodgers it competed
well with the Dodgers whether it all
plays out in their favor that remains to
be seen but I applauded what they did I
do not have a problem with it at all
and I don't really think baseball fans
should have a problem with it teams are
being creative now trying to figure out
ways to win it leads to more
conversation like the one we're having
and in my view it's healthy okay so and
again I won't put you the position of
predicting Ken but before I let you go
you know when you ask a team that's
already made the championship round who
would you like to face of the two teams
that they would possibly have a chance
to face and they would always say well
we'll take whoever we get deep down who
are the Red Sox rooting for over these
final two games of the NL see what you
think Milwaukee and it's because of the
lack of starting pitching deaths and the
fact that they have to use all these
bodies going into this series
the Brewers biggest fear was that the
pitching would be exhausted over seven
games now we've seen some great
performances from their entire staff
even guys at the bottom of the staff
like Freddy Peralta and Luger Guerra but
and they sustain it
over seven games can hagar hold up over
seven games it needs are all fair
questions and against the Red Sox one of
the most dynamic offensive teams we've
seen for years it would be that much
more challenging the Dodgers their
starters go deeper into games or at
least they have I don't know they would
again to the Red Sox and the bullpen has
performed extremely well surprisingly
well actually in this series so if I'm
the Red Sox I'd rather see the Brewers
okay can't really appreciate the the
chat here from Milwaukee on the day of
game six have a great cast tonight
really enjoy your work mobile chat again
during the World Series that hope thanks
very much you bet that's Ken Rosenthal
the Rich Eisen show weekdays at noon
eastern on audience